AM IN LONDON, 11 AM IN MOSCOW,
WHERE THE KREMLIN HAS KICKED
OFF CELEBRATIONS FOR VICTORY
DAY, A NATIONAL HOLIDAY MARKING
THE DEFEAT OF NAZI GERMANY IN
WORLD WAR II.
BUT THOSE CELEBRATIONS WERE
OVERSHADOWED BY RUSSIA'S OWN
WARN UKRAINE.
AS MOSCOW HOLDS ITS ANNUAL PREY
TO SHOWCASE MOSCOW'S MILITARY
MIGHT, SEVERAL REGIONS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY SCALE BACK ADVANCED
AMID SECURITY CONCERNS AND A
LACK OF MILITARY EQUIPMENT.
IN JUST LAST, HOUR WE HEARD
FROM PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN,
HE SAID HE WANTS A PEACEFUL
FUTURE AND CLAIMED THE TRUE WAR
IS BEING WAGED AGAINST THIS
COUNTRY.
>> EVEN AS A MIXED VICTORY DAY,
OR PERHAPS ESPECIALLY, RUSSIA
HAS NOT STOPPED ITS ATTACKS ON
UKRAINE.
THE UKRAINIAN AIR FORCE SAYS IT
INTERCEPTED 23 OUT OF 25 CRUISE
MISSILES, WITH AN OFFICIAL --
SAYING 15 WERE DESTROYED OVER
THE CITY TODAY.
BUT MORE AIDE IS HEADED TO
UKRAINE, AHEAD OF A LOOMING
COUNTEROFFENSIVE.
THE U.S. IS SET TO ANNOUNCE A
1.2 BILLION DOLLAR PACKAGE AS
EARLY AS TODAY, INCLUDING
DRONES, AMMUNITION, AND AIR
DEFENSE MISSILES.
THE PACKAGE IS GEARED TOWARDS
THE COUNTRY MEDIUM TO LONG TERM
SECURITY NEEDS.
>> CNN'S CLARE SEBASTIAN
FOLLOWING ALL THIS FOR US IN
LONDON.
AN INTERNATIONAL DIPLOMATIC
EDITOR NIC ROBERTSON IS LIVE IN
EASTERN.
UKRAINE IS THERE A SENSE OF
TENSION THAT'S AROUND THIS
MOMENTOUS DAY THERE, NIC?
[SILENCE]
LET'S GO TO CLARE.
>> JUST AS WE'RE FIXING THE
COMMUNICATION ISSUES, AS MACK,
SAID THIS IS A MOMENTOUS DAY IN
RUSSIA.
WE ALSO DON'T GET TO HEAR
VLADIMIR PUTIN SPEAK THAT
OFTEN.
SO, WHEN HE DOES, A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO
EXTRAPOLATE WHERE HIS STRATEGY
MIGHT BE HEADING, OR ANY HINTS
THAT WE CAN'T.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF HIS SPEECH?
>> I, MEAN IT WAS BARELY TEN
MINUTES LONG.
AND HE SQUEEZED IN THE NORMAL
LINES YOU HEAR IN HIS STUMP
SPEECHES, HIS JUSTIFICATION'S
FOR THE WARNING CRANE.
INTERESTINGLY, A RELATIVELY
SMALL PROPORTION OF IT SPENT
REFERRING TO THE SECOND WORLD
WAR, WHICH IS WHAT THIS ENTIRE
WAR IS ABOUT.
HE SAID THE WEST IS GUNNING FOR
GLOBAL SUPREMACY, THEY WANT TO
CRUSH RUSSIA, THEY'RE PROMOTING
RUSSOPHOBIA, ALL THE THINGS
WE'RE USED TO HEARING, EVEN
DOWN TO DESTROYING FAMILY
VALUES, THINK THAT MAKE YOU A
HUMAN BEING.
EVEN SQUEEZED IN WHAT SEEMS TO
BE ONE OF HIS TRADITIONAL
DENIALS OF UKRAINIAN
SOVEREIGNTY.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> [INTERPRETER]
THE UKRAINIAN NATION HAS BECOME
HOSTAGE TO A --
WHICH LED TO A CRIMINAL REGIME
LED BY ITS WESTERN MASTERS.
IT HAS BECOME A PAWN TO THEIR
CRUEL AND SELFISH PLANS.
>> [SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH]
>> UKRAINE IS UPON ON THE, WEST
WE'VE HEARD THIS FROM PUTIN
BEFORE.
OBVIOUSLY, THAT MAKES RUSSIANS
SETBACKS IN UKRAINE'S A LITTLE
LESS HUMILIATING, GIVEN THAT
RUSSIA CONTINUES TO REFER TO
THE WEST ARMING UKRAINE AND ALL
OF THAT.
THIS OF COURSE COMES JUST SIX
DAYS AFTER SEVERAL DRONES HIT
THE KREMLIN, JUST STEPS FROM
WHERE IS MAKING THAT SPEECH.
THIS MAY HAVE BEEN A VEILED
REFERENCE TO THE ANXIETY AND
INSECURITY AROUND RUSSIA AROUND
THAT THE TOP OF THE SPEECH.
HE SAID A TRUE WAR HAS BEEN
UNLEASHED AGAINST OUR
MOTHERLAND.
RUSSIA HAS REPELLED
INTERNATIONAL TERRORISM.
YOU KNOW, I THINK WE DO FEEL A
SENSE OF INSECURITY, PART OF
THE JUSTIFICATION OF THE WARREN
UKRAINE ALL ALONG IS THAT
RUSSIA IS UNDER SIEGE.
THE WEST IS TRYING TO DESTROY
RUSSIA, AND THEY ARE IN A SENSE
TRYING TO DEFEND THEIR OWN
INTEREST IN UKRAINE.
BUT I THINK WHAT YOU GOT FROM
THE SPEECH IS, A, NOTHING NEW,
AND BE, A SENSE HE'S NOT
BACKING, DOWN HE'S GOT TO
CONTINUE TO TRY AND CROSS OVER
THE SETBACKS IN UKRAINE,
JUSTIFIED FOR IS, PEOPLE I KEEP
ON WITH THIS FIGHT.
>> ALL RIGHT, LET'S TRY
SHOOTING TWO NIC AGAIN.
NIC, JUST DESCRIBE THE
ATMOSPHERE ON THAT SIDE OF THE
BORDER, AS THESE COMMEMORATIONS
ARE MARKED IN MOSCOW.
>> YEAH, YOU CAN PROBABLY HEAR
THE AIR RAID WARNING SIRENS
GOING OFF RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS A COMMON OCCURRENCE
HERE.
EVERYONE WHO LIVES IN THIS AREA
OF EASTERN UKRAINE IS USED TO
IT.
AND MOST PEOPLE JUST SHRUG AND
CARRY ON.
ALTHOUGH THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
HEAVY EXPLOSIONS NOT SO FAR
AWAY, AFTER WE HEARD AN
AIRCRAFT FLYING OVER.
SO, I THINK, YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU
ARE IN THE EAST OF UKRAINE, YOU
REALLY SEE, AND RELATIVELY
CLOSE TO BAKHMUT, HE REALLY
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A
POTENTIAL INFLECTION POINT IN
THIS WAR, BECAUSE THE
UKRAINIANS ARE WATCHING EVERY
RUSSIAN MOVE ON THIS FRONT LINE
SO CLOSELY, EXTRA CLOSELY
AROUND THE TIME A VICTORY
PARADE, BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT
PUTIN WANTS TO SCORE'S SUCCESS
IN BAKHMUT, THEY BELIEVE THEY'D
LIKE NOTHING BETTER TO BE ABLE
TO SAY AND WE'VE TAKEN THE
CITY.
WHY?
BECAUSE HE HAS DONE SO BADLY
ABOUT TAKING ANY LARGE
UKRAINIAN CITY OR TOWN SINCE
THE FRONTLINES EFFECTIVELY
BECAME FROZEN ALONG HERE,
ALMOST A YEAR OR SO AGO, A
LITTLE MORE THAN A YEAR AGO, IN
THE EARLY STAGES OF THE WAR.
AND FROM THE RUSSIAN
PERSPECTIVE, THEY ARE WATCHING
SO CLOSELY BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
SEE WHERE AND WHEN AND HOW
UKRAINIANS LAUNCHED THIS MUCH
ANTICIPATED COUNTEROFFENSIVE.
SO, I THINK PERHAPS
HISTORICALLY WE WILL BE ABLE TO
LOOK BACK THIS DAY AND SEE HOW
BOTH SIDES HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
EVALUATE HOW, A VALIDATE WHAT'S
GOING ON ON THE FRONT LINE, AND
THEREFORE, WHAT THEIR NEXT
MOVES ARE GOING TO BE.
IS THIS THE MOMENT WHEN THE
UKRAINIANS WATCH WHAT THE
RUSSIANS HAVE DONE AT THIS
MOMENT OF HIGH TENSION AND THEN
DECIDE THERE FOR ABOUT HOW
THEY'LL MAKE THEIR NEXT MOVES
IN THE COUNTEROFFENSIVE,
KNOWING THAT THE
COUNTEROFFENSIVE IS A
COMPLICATED, PROTRACTED, AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL WAR WITH RUSSIANS
AT TIMES AS WELL, SORT OF
STRING OUT THEIR SUPPLY LINES,
STOPPING TROOP MORALE, WHO IS
SORT OF ALL THE TIME WHEN THE
BIG PUSH IS GOING TO COME.
SO, HERE TODAY, THE EXPECTATION
IS THERE COULD BE QUITE HEAVY
FIGHTING ALONG THE FRONT LINE,
AND YOU CAN CERTAINLY HEAR
THOSE DISTANT EXPLOSIONS.
AND AS I SAY, FIGHTER AIRCRAFT
IN THE SKY, BOMBS FALLING,
THAT'S WHAT IT SOUNDS LIKE.
AND OF COURSE, WITH THE AIR
RAID SOUNDS GOING OFF, IT'S